[Musique]
bruxelles capitale de l'europe et c'est
ici que se joue une partie de l'avenir
de la réunion
pendant deux jours le quatrième forum
des rup les régions ultrapériphériques
s'est déroulée devant près de 500
convives
l'enjeu est conséquent obtenir de
l'europe une écoute attentive des
attentes réunionnaise car c'est en ce
moment que se décident les prochains
plans de financement de l'union
européenne
pour l'occasion la délégation
réunionnaise est venu en force et
parfaitement préparé
objectif affiché consolider certaines
filières locales en danger notamment la
canne à sucre très attentive lors des
débats nassimah dindar a profité de
chaque occasion pour pousser en avant
les initiatives réunionnaise et parler
de citoyenneté européenne en plénière en
atelier ou lors des pauses
la présidente du conseil départemental à
faire dans ce lot mais il y à combiner a
fait du lobbying ici en étant présent en
europe vous construire le modèle de
demain et pour combiner des politiques
publiques en assouplissant les normes en
faisant que chaque réunionnais puissent
avoir les moyens d'être un citoyen
européen
c'est bien la citoyenneté européenne
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui construire
après 2020 c'est pas seulement de
l'argent de l'europe c'est comment les
hommes s'ils vont s'adapter pour que un
agriculteur à la réunion ils puissent
vivre de sa terre et de son outil de
travail
un chef d'entreprise le mont économique
puisse avoir son produit en n'ayant pas
la concurrence des pays voisins
c'est de tout cela que le président de
la région les parlementaires jean paul
virapoullé moi-même étaient tous les
techniciens qui nous accompagnent voilà
pourquoi nous sommes ici pour rencontrer
des gens expliqué demande et faire du
lobbying au fonds vendent la réunion de
demain
l'action de la présidente du département
et notamment de mettre en cohérence les
finances du feder le fonds de
subventions agricoles avec les règles
européennes
de son côté didier robert le président
du conseil régional a présenté à la
commissaire européenne pour la politique
régionale
les grands axes de développement que la
réunion soit assurée dans la décennie à
venir
il a présenté un mémorandum avec 150
composition la commission européenne a
d'ores et déjà assuré qu'elle
compenserait le coup de l'éloignement
mais pour l'heure aucun chiffre n'a été
avancé
bilan et perspectives des fonds
européens notamment agricoles
financement d'infrastructures continuité
territoriale compétitivité des
entreprises
les sujets abordés ont été nombreux les
perspectives sont positives
c'est la porte ouverte à enfin pour un
nouveau modèle de développement qui va
prendre en compte nos handicaps nos
richesses conjuguer les uns avec les
autres pour mettre la réunion et les
ruptures bildu développe le forum a
également été l'occasion de mettre en
avant les atouts des îles notamment la
production de biocarburants grâce au
micro algues souvent on parle de
l'outre-mer de des handicaps de
l'outre-mer aujourd'hui grâce à des
technologies comme celle que l'on que
l'on propose on ne parle plus de
handicaps mais davantage compétitif pour
l'europe nous sommes l'europe de l'océan
indien avec cet avantage d'avoir un
climat qui nous permet de produire ces
microalgues là où il est compliqué de le
faire en europe et donc en la réunion
gagne quand les rues de gagne c'est pas
simplement la france qui gagne mais
c'est l'europe qui gagnent
pour les 9 rue qui accumule un retard de
développement au sein de l'union cette
séquence est vital
l'europe doit nous entendre et adapter
sa politique à nos attentes et pour cela
ils jouent collectif tous les
territoires ultramarins travaillent main
dans la main
combien de mémorandum des prêts
des régions ultra périphériques combien
de discours au parlement européen
combien d'efforts depuis des années et
des années pour qu'enfin nous rentrions
dans le concret que tout est pays qui
composent ce que l'on appelle les
régions djokovic reste solidaire pour
pouvoir des fon lozano pense que c'est
une démarche commune globale qui
concerne tous et toutes les rues nous
avons devant nous six mois de travail
parce que la future politique
2 pour les rues au niveau de l'union
européenne sera mise au public à la fin
de cette année donc nous avons encore du
temps avec notre force et notre énergie
au niveau de la réunion et des autres
d'affaires de nous faire entendre en
plus haut niveau à lacanau ces accords
commerciaux clause de sauvegarde pour
l'agriculture emploi et mobilité énergie
environnement l'europe brasse de
nombreux sujets qui pourrait être un
formidable coup d'accélérateur pour
l'économie réunionnaise
ce forum doit permettre à la commission
de valider ses réponses
des réponses qui tomberont en décembre
[Musique]